did i get him holy sh
what a way to start up four membranes
off the bag
good morning gamers haha
all right i i completely forgot i need
the phantom membranes
literally right now this is the only
time i'll need him because today is a
very special day
today we're fighting the ender dragon
this could be the last time i get to see
my beautiful
my fire nation temple this could be at
gamers
i am legit a little bit nervous because
obviously
i could fall down who invited you
and there's just there's nothing you
know all the best gear in the world
isn't gonna save me from
from that happening so i'm gonna do what
i can to avoid that [ __ ]
so what i need is portion of feather
falling to avoid
the dragon flapping his wings
get in the water you stinky boo boo
yeah supper not you i love you
um so let's make some potions
i don't think i'll need i mean maybe
i'll make some health potions just
just to be epic ah yes evil cat girl
bath water it makes the potions more
potent there we go thank you
i can't believe i thanked you you stinky
[ __ ] uh
and i think you use phantom membrane for
the potion of falling i'm not sure maybe
i should check it out because i won't
waste them
you wish you wish i die yeah i wish
you'd die
or you just drown already it's still
hard i'm sorry
it's okay it's okay to be sucky at
everything in life
it's okay to just be a nuisance to
everyone in the universe
it's not your fault alright so now we
have slow falling
uh oh i also know you can get the
dragon's breath
so i want to make sure i remember to
bring a bunch of
empty vials jump down
perfect my bed jump down mechanism works
so well
ah look at my automatic melons yes look
at them go through
all of them wow this could be the last
time i see my automatic smelting system
sorting system i speaking of which i
forgot to tell you i
realized my dream it looks awful but
it works so basically what i did is i
added another component i don't know
what to call it
uh to the system first of all i fix
these so
they don't intertwine anymore and i have
four
they all go to the four chests so they
shoot out pretty quickly
i don't remember shooting why are they
getting shot at
okay anyway so here i added another
sorting system
in between that everything passes
through before they get sorted
and in them is coal iron bars i mean we
can check it out
uh netherrack i met netherrack uh
ironworts
coal so the coal goes to a separate
channel over there
and the other items that i want to melt
goes in here
which goes into my automatic smelter and
then
the cool part is that the automatic
smelter goes out here and it shoots out
as soon as it's done
which goes back into the system into my
storage so the netherrack
that got smelted [ __ ] directly
in here why are they not here what the
[ __ ]
i was so proud for a moment what is
happening where did they go
where did they go oh my [ __ ] god dude
i must have put it somewhere else oh how
[ __ ] lame
it's supposed to go in here yeah why
oh my god what happened here
why are these here did i never connect
it did i forget no they're supposed to
be connected
something happened at some point and i
don't know why is this a pump
oh i'm so confused oh it i could
actually make it connected here
is that a bad idea i understand what
went wrong but hold up hold on
okay okay i can fix this easy there we
go now it works
am i gonna have to put myself through
the system to get out of here
all right here we go i'm getting
automatically sorted guys here we go
can't wait to see where i end up
all right now it works all right that
was unfortunate i didn't get to show you
but yeah all right you understand
it works now oh look guys they got
automatically sorted there wow that's so
cool
oh they are filling up they are feeling
good you saw that you saw that [ __ ]
what was i doing i forgot all right the
ender dragon
so another cool thing about the dragon
which i didn't know about
is that uh it shoots his dragon breath
and it's the only time you
can collect it as far as i know and you
can collect it with these
uh glass bottles which you can then use
to make
uh arrows and you can make one of the
best arrows in the game
by using that so obviously i want to
take this chance to
yeah get as much of that as possible i
know you can summon the dragon one more
time
but uh i want to take advantage of the
dragon i'll say it all right i don't
know if i showed you but yeah i moved
them here and i got melon and
pumpkin right now i love my world i'm
super excited about it it's getting
better
and better than where i work on it this
is really fun
and honestly it will be so heart
crushing to lose this world at this
point
so you better not curse me you stinker i
think i'm gonna do a sleep and then uh
we're have
we're ready to head off yeah i know it's
good to bring boats
um i don't think i need it oh let me
talk to the salesman i'm trying to get
a coral block i don't know if he sells
them but
wow salesman just left you guys that's
kind of [ __ ]
all right well enjoy bye bye
one last look
here we go
uh yeah i don't the road isn't safe but
whatever
it's this way oh wow it's really not
safe this road what the hell
i'll make it safe eventually don't worry
i don't see how many times i'm gonna go
to the dragon to be honest
here we go there's our portal to the
stronghold
this is it thanks for sticking with my
channel this is the second time i'll be
beating the dragon
all right
[Music]
gamers oh
get pumped let's do this
okay we're in the end cool
so we're in this box we have to dig our
way to the dragon i have no idea where
he is
i don't know if it's good it's probably
good that i'm in a box because that
means i'm on the mainland at least
i know what happened to phil's that
there was a glitch in his hardcore mode
that
as soon as he went to the end it just
threw him
away oh we're already here whoa this
looks so
cool oh the fog looks so cool it makes
it a little difficult but whoa what a
weird oh this is a weird island let's
check here be careful
okay it doesn't look too bad but yeah
the battle has begun
let me just collect a couple of these
make sure we don't interact with
the enders men this looks so sick
he doesn't know the dragon doesn't know
all right
i don't want to aggro
what the [ __ ] oh there's the breath
oh it does damage okay okay so now i can
collect this dragon spread
why is my inventory full yeah there we
go
i think it disappears if you collect it
too which is really cool all right
let's shoot these one down
let's go distance
nope we really gotta watch out for his
wings
like i should have brought more ender
pearls a little low
two [ __ ]
give me your breath my dude
nice got some more breath is it too far
away
oh he keeps shooting me dude
it's kind of funny just like taking it
i'm shooting too low i see now oh that
was close
that looked like a hit oh my god i think
i made one of the endermen
angry so far so good
i can't seem to can hit him too low my
dude
there we go stop shooting me
oh we anchored one which one
what's up enderman we're on the same
team right let me just eat a golden
carrot that's right i'm so rich
i'm not looking at you leave me alone
nice i'll take that i know you can make
an ender pearl
or enderman farm here all right that was
close
how did the speedrunners do it there we
go
yes let's go so
i think oh he's a mad pose man okay
now what we have to do is we have to dig
ourselves up
i really gotta make sure he doesn't use
his breath on me here so i'm gonna try
and find an angle
he just shot it missed me [ __ ] and then
let's
dig this out let's make sure we don't
hit the thing i'm not sure how much i'm
supposed to remove here
okay taking it easy taking it cool
he's shooting me that's fine we're just
taking the easy way out
clean okay now we gotta shoot it
all right just a couple more whoa
they're all attacking him look at them
they're super pissed maybe enderman not
bad after all
wow open my eyes my third eye
oh he's shooting the ball okay good
i don't think it's hurting me clean
clean i clean it oh that's bad
i kind of panicked there i don't know
maybe let's do it like this
oh this is really bad
whoa dude whoa
dude hold on hold on hold on hold on
okay i thought i had this in the bag for
a sec that was [ __ ]
oh okay let's not jinx this guys
all right i think i can get an angle on
this
yes there's one more there's one more
there's one more then we can start
hurting the dragon
that's really [ __ ] tall though damn
once that's the thing about hardcore
like everything seems fine
until it doesn't and then it's over
before you know it
right come on dude god i hate how much
they teleport
i like how i'm about to get like the
elytra but i'm more excited about the
dragon spray
i might have to climb up to that one
it's so
how do i get an angle on that whoa
so he flapped his wings there that's
what we really got to wash ourself out
for
can i get an angle on this or what it's
so [ __ ] tall
i got it that was [ __ ] pro dude all
right he's going down
you're going down my dude such a cool
boss
oh gosh sure i'll collect your breath
whatever
your stinky ass breath my dude all right
okay so now what i can do is i can drink
the potion right and i can go in and do
some damage
[ __ ] you [ __ ] suck my
ass i hey okay he didn't flap his wings
so i'm not sure what happened there but
i have the potion on me
oh what a shot what a shot
oh what a shot oh what a shot oh what a
shot
don't shoot me don't you back what's
wrong with you come down [ __ ]
oh got him more breath
oh no he's collecting his breath oh no
oh he's going down we can start doing
damage
just got to watch out for those wings
man
is it going down it'll be close
oh we might no dang it
oh here we go guys
hardcore mode [ __ ] they said it
couldn't be done [ __ ]
and there it is
ow
oh look at him explode
get that xp give me that sweet xp
oh level level level oh
100 baby give me 200.
and there's the dragon's egg i know you
can grab that but i forgot how i'll i'll
probably look
look it up i think you need a piston
right oh that feels good
surprisingly didn't agree with that many
endermen so now we need to go through
that
um it's kind of awkward place are there
are there more of them
oh this does not feel good why is it so
far away
right oh i do not i'm not a fan of this
hands are sweaty bomb my baby what
happens if i miss my ender pearl and
oh god the threat is not over i could
seriously mess up here not a fan my
hands
are next level of sweat here i don't i
don't feel comfortable
i'm gonna be safe here and build a
platform around this
because what if i come back and then i
just like fall down
oh my god dude why is it here i thought
they appear like
ugh mo jang apologize
great i only have dirt blocks
am i being like paranoid here i don't
know man
no chances in keynes all right so we
throw the ender pedal through
and we're through whoa
is there always like that a beacon is
that new i think that's new i never seen
that before
that's really cool no what it
disappeared
what anyway now we're in the end
and we have to look for an end city
i know you can mine these and melt these
if you eat them you teleport
kind of cool this is why i wanted to
bring bonky i forgot about that
because i you have to walk so far here
to get the
get to the end city it'd be so cool to
get the elytra
i find myself like hunching down and not
looking at them even in real life
such a beta i know it doesn't seem like
a big deal to go down to like three or
four hearts but in hardcore
it really is and i was really scared at
one point
yeah but shouldn't i be able to just put
a trapdoor and then walk through yeah
yeah
why don't i oh god it's so dumb to do
the uh whatever
i'm gonna drink another potion because
i'm a weirdo [ __ ]
all right here we go oh
[Music]
you know what you know what game was i
think i'm going home
i think i had enough for the day
the dragon egg can wait the dragon egg
can weigh
there it is the end of minecraft
and it takes it back home to your spawn
that's cool i like that nice
yeah look who came back [ __ ]
now we have the dragon's breath and now
we add this to it
the dragon's breath oh this is so cool i
never done this
is it cool i don't know now they become
lingering potion of harming and we
sleep and i think you just make them in
a crafting bench
it doesn't give me the option that i can
do it which is a little concerning
yeah i can only make eight
all that for eight arrows oh my god dude
well now that we have the most powerful
arrow in the game i think i'm not sure
let's try it out i'm curious
what's up alabama i know
i'll move you eventually ah
beautiful what a gorgeous day today what
a blessed day
i'm so happy dude who's gonna get the
first taste
which poor piggling is it gonna be funny
how the nether doesn't seem dangerous at
all once you've been in the end oh here
we go
all right it's got pants it's got gucci
pants here we go
are you serious i've been missed
yeah it's instant death oh
let's use it on the baby
okay so these have a lot of hell
how are you still alive maybe they're
not that good i don't know maybe that
was all the waste of
time who knows i did it it's cool
it's cool maybe i should make some other
arrows i don't know but that's cool
say it's cool wow felix that's so cool
and that's how cool you did that
thank you thank you anyway i feel great
thanks to everyone for supporting this
series i want to continue
because i i love my world and i want to
keep seeing what i can do with it
it's been such a fun journey to really
dig deeper into minecraft and learn more
about it and
doing all these different dumb [ __ ] like
i love it
it's been so fun so huge thanks guys
i'll see you in the next one hater